Now that we have finished our grass,
let's talk about physical materials.
Now, physical materials allow you to assign
different physical properties
to various surfaces in your project.
And a surface could be anything like a static mesh,
or in our case, we're gonna show you
how to assign surfaces
inside of your material via textures.
Now, the cool thing about physical materials
is they can not only represent things like density
or how bouncy something is,
but they can also be used to do things like spawn particles
or spawn different sounds when a user encounters
or interacts with different surfaces.
For us, what we're gonna do is
we are just going to make two physical materials.
We're gonna make one for our dirt
and one for our grass.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor
and do that now.
So I'm gonna hit Control space,
and I'm just gonna right-click inside of here.
I'm gonna go to physics,
and then we're gonna come down here to physical material.
Now, when I do this,
I am gonna be asked what physical material class
I wanna base this off of.
So we're gonna select physical material and click select.
We're gonna give this a new name of pm underscore dirt.
And then instead of doing that again,
I'm just gonna right-click on this
and duplicate and call this new one grass.
And then I'm just going to save both of those.
So the next thing that we need to do with this
is inside of our material,
there is a landscape physical material output node.
And with this node,
what we can do is bring it into our graph.
And then in the details panel,
we can add as many inputs
as we have physical materials that need this.
Now, one thing to note here,
we wanna try to keep these things
as optimized as possible.
So if you have five or six materials in your landscape,
but you really only need two or three of those
to actually have physical materials,
that's the best way to approach this.
Remember, less is always better
when you're dealing with real-time applications.
So let's go ahead and pop open our material
and add this node and get it ready to be set up.
So we're gonna come over here to our matte landscape.
There we go.
And then I'm just gonna come up here
to where my BC dirt and my BC grass are,
and I'm gonna right-click
and we're gonna look for our landscape.
And we're gonna come down here
and look for our landscape physical material outputs.
We're gonna go ahead and grab that.
And then, like I said before, in the details panel,
we're gonna add one and two elements to this.
And if we just come here and scroll down,
we'll see our PM dirt and our PM grass.
Now we are gonna get this message
that the physical material input is missing
and we have it twice because we have two inputs here.
So what we're actually gonna do with this
is we're now going to go to our BC dirt
and our BC grass textures
and actually plug those
right into this physical material output node.
Yes, it is literally that simple.
All we have to do to define
which part of our landscape material we want to have,
this physics or this physics,
is literally just wire that texture
into this respective node and we will get that.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
We're gonna pop back over here to the editor
and we're just gonna take our BC dirt, whoops,
and we're gonna take the output of our BC dirt, there we go,
and then we're gonna do the same thing for our grass.
We're just gonna plug that in
and we're going to hit apply and save.
All right, now, in order to check this,
what we can do is inside of our console,
we can input the following command,
landscape.collisionmesh.showphysicalmaterial equal,
or you can say equal to one or one.
And what this is going to do
is this is actually going to allow us
to see the differences where the physical material
for one texture is used
versus the physical material for another texture,
and we can see that right here.
So let's go ahead and just pop back in it
to our editor right here.
And in order to do this, first off,
we're gonna hit Alt C on the keyboard,
and then I'm gonna paste this command right in here
and press enter, and there we go.
That is showing you the difference
between those two physical materials.
So we can see here, one is right here
and then the other is right there.
And then kind of as they are mixing through this,
we are getting different values there.
So this wraps it up for this portion
of our video tutorial.